so tell us how your life intersected
with Brian's why you wanted to make this
movie and how your grandparents were
involved Wow
so it all started when I was dating my
now wife Jamie Newman she's over there
and I was looking for my first us topic
as to feature so I was sitting in a
coffee shop in Tel Aviv it was five six
years ago and I saw this article in
newspaper
it's islets paper which is the New York
Times of Israel and I saw this montage
of kind of a Brian Widener from being
tattooed fully tattooed to clean face
and I read the story behind that about
him and about Julie and about their home
on Jenkins and I was blown away by that
and then I went to my grandfather who is
my mentor and my my big big love and he
read it with me and he said that this is
something that I need to do so he gave
me the green light to do that and I
needed it because it's not an easy story
but you know he taught he taught us
compassion he taught he taught us about
acceptance about dialog and it was
important for him he accepted the new
generation of Germans and he said
they're not the same and you know it
took him some time after he came to
Israel after the war but he taught us
that so I got in touch with Brian
Widener through MSNBC I got his email I
wrote him an email but my grandparents
about myself and we set up a Skype call
my wife and I Skype with him and his
wife and he told mas he told us that if
we're really serious we should come to
Albuquerque to meet him and his wife we
flew to Albuquerque we met with them and
they signed the life rights over a
napkin
so I wanted to tell this so I started
writing the script with him helping me
and no one in the States wanted to give
me money to tell the story because they
said that you know there's no really
neo-nazis in the states it's just a myth
it's it's just a bunch of like five six
people in the Midwest it's not really a
thing and you know Hillary is about to
become president so it's not so I was
bummed and I was you know and then Trump
got elected charlotte's will happened
the synagogue Massacre the whole thing
became crazy and we did the short so
that's that's the story of it Jamie when
this project came to you what did you
think what did you feel
did you have any fear anxiety I mean you
had to go pretty dark can't mean a
slightly kind of obtuse fashion oh one
of the producers on the film or and move
them and I met him for a film that he
was considering directing and we met
around Christmastime and it was days
away from me proposing to my Nair wife
so I was kind of nervous about that and
and we talked a lot about that and
marriage and kids and family and stuff
but I got I got the sense pretty quick
that that film specifically was never
gonna be male that he just hadn't it
wasn't it wasn't gonna be the next thing
he did so that's why we talked about all
this other stuff and then shortly after
Christmas into the new year I got this
script and I remember thinking like what
on earth did he see in me during that
meeting that he would think that I could
do something like this he said my friend
guy is directing it I think you should
meet him and I didn't know anything
about Brian whiner upon reading it and
obviously so how great a writer guy was
and and how
such a complicated complex character
that I would get to play we met we
actually met in Virginia and we had long
discussions and Kanna had long
discussions up until we could started
the cameras rolling but I went up to
meet Bryan hung out with him for a while
and on other while the timeline of this
is that is that the country is exploding
and it seemed like the world is
exploding and I was always kind of like
God is this is the right kind of climate
for us to be making this film and is
this the right thing to be doing but it
it felt like a huge wake-up call
honestly and what I keep seeing more
often than not is that is that these
people and these guy in these groups and
they appear to be kind of radically
normalized to such a horrendous degree
that I never want that to be the case I
want them and I think that's what guy's
intention always was is to paint these
people for who they are the world as it
really is and I thought that was the
correct perspective in the correct way
to tell a story how did that go when you
met Bryan I'm curious how do you play a
character like that without judging him
I mean it's very common I mean I have a
really hard time with forgiveness just
in my own life
so you know they always tell you like
you shouldn't judge the character that
you're playing it's gonna be impossible
for you to play him if you're always
judging them so I was very hesitant to
go for me and I was kind of scared to
meet him I I done my research by that
point guy had painted a very clear
picture of who he was from the script
you know this this man was the guy that
law enforcement was always very
concerned about they were they always
thought this was the guy that was the
most insightful
he was the enforcer he was the thug he
was they called him the pit bull sure
they called him the pit bull yeah
exactly so and you've obviously seen
what he looks like
so I imagined in a meeting that honestly
did you Circle the coffee shop five
times before you know I saw a guy like
on the on the drive to him I saw
another guy with his hand out of his car
like waving a pistol around so I was
like okay this I guess you must be
getting close I'm getting but upon what
what is crazy is you open the guy opens
the door and if you didn't know that
that's the way he looked you would never
know
I mean he's be truly in that sense been
given a gift of a new life but beyond
that and you know he was very incredibly
generous with his time incredibly
articulate human being would often
interrupt the interviews to go and pick
up his kids I would say intensely
paranoid is this kind of guy as
mentioned he's gonna live a life of
reckoning and I wife in determined but
he's choosing a better path you know and
he's been given that by the kindness of
other people and he knows that I think
Danielle I sort of felt like Julie was
done as a stand-in for us the viewer you
know she was struggling to love him
struggling to understand him and accept
him and sort of reconcile all this have
you ever known anybody like that in your
life and how do you love a neo-nazi I
don't know it took me a while to figure
that one out
um honestly yeah when I when I took on
the role it was it was it was that thing
of how do I not judge this character
because in my brain it was like you meet
this person you know what he is why are
you with him why are you pursuing it and
that was really difficult to me I had to
talk to guy a lot about that I was like
but but why but why and guy kept saying
you know it's it's not they don't think
the way that you do like we all think
very differently and I had to go back to
her history and she grew up in the
movement like her dad was in it and that
was all she knew her boyfriend's before
that were in it like she didn't know any
other way of life and she was trying to
get out of it and struggling because the
only watch she could get was in it and
it's this thing of where she was still
living in that world trying not to so
when she meets someone that she sees has
a soul that has a heart that is also in
it it's it's almost like they can help
each other get out and in a weird way I
think she sensed that and she saw that
before he saw it and
self you know Brian's often said like
Julie really was such a huge reason like
why he was able to get out it like
pushed him to actually take the steps to
do it and I that's that's how I kind of
came to the character and also she's a
mom and she loved her kids more than
anything she kind of knew growing up
growing up and so that was that was kind
of how I found my way in and stop
judging huh I wondered what you guys did
together to you know to establish the
relationship before guys started rolling
we're always trying to like figure out
why are these people choosing to do
things that we wouldn't do that was
always a kind of battle that we were up
against right I mean it always you know
just from from one scene to the next
they kind of start making these very
strange decisions and start acting in
ways that I couldn't recognize you know
I was always trying to like kind of see
things work in a rational prism you know
and guy was always like oh that's
completely incorrect these are
irrational people that's not the way to
do well done and thank you for joining
us to talk about it